History unfolding at the U.S.
Capitol today
with the January 6th Select Committees
announcement of four criminal referrals
against Donald Trump.
The panel arguing
Trump
should never be allowed to serve
in a position of authority again.
But in a new clip
played by the committee,
Trump's longtime aide and confidant
Hope Hicks
made it clear
that Trump's primary goal
has always been winning too expensive.
Anything else?
Listen to her describe a conversation
she had with Trump
about his claims of voter fraud
being evidence of
fraud on a scale that would have impacted
the outcome of the election
and I was
becoming increasingly concerned that
we were damaging
we were damaging his legacy
say in response
to what you just described,
he said something along the lines of
you know,
nobody will care about my legacy
if I lose
so that won't matter.
The only thing that matters is,
is winning
All right.
So let's put some perspective and context
on this
with our team of veterans
from the Watergate
era, the legendary journalist
Bob Woodward
and Carl Bernstein
and the former Nixon White House counsel
John Dean.
John, you know,
she said all he cared about was winning.
And if he didn't win,
he'd have no legacy.
Of course, now he does have a legacy.
So what stands out to you
the most from what she said
and what we've learned today?
Well, what she said
is that he's going to have the wrong
legacy.
Have the legacy of a loser
and that's not a legacy he can handle.
What stood out to me
was the very beginning.
The chairman,
in a passing remark
said what we're sending
to the Department of Justice
is a roadmap.
Well, that just clicked right away
because during Watergate,
it was just the reverse.
The special prosecutors
sent the Congress a roadmap.
So I think that's the way
they envision this document
and this material,
because they've been here much longer.
Than the Department of Justice.
They've been looking at this evidence.
So I'm sure they're quite familiar
with where these roads go,
with where they go. Right.
And all the all the transcripts
and backup information
that they have
that they haven't given
to the Department of Justice yet.
What what do you think
is the most important thing
from what you've now seen?
Well, they're for referrals here.
And I think the one that's important
is the one that says it is a crime
to subvert a lawful function
of government.
In the lawful function of government
is where,
according to the 12th Amendment
to the Constitution,
the president of the Senate,
who in this case, Vice President
Pence, oversees the counting of the votes
And I think the part of the evidence
that is most significant
legally and most reprehensible
is when Trump was pressuring Pence.
Here's Trump, the boss, the subordinate.
And he's saying,
you're not going to be my friend.
You're a wimp. You're betraying us.
And that
in just a normal case, with the boss
putting that kind of
pressure on a subordinate
is almost a crime in itself.
And of course,
once you prove one of these,
they they each come
with multiple year sentences.
But but anything would be
hugely significant, I mean, to say that.
Yeah, but I think for people are going
to have to sort this out
just like the Justice Department.
What's important, what's not important.
And I think this is the one and I
quite frankly,
think it will resonate
and it does resonate with people.
I mean,
what's the president of the United States
talking to the vice president?
I'm not going to be your friend.
We joke
that it's
as if Trump was saying the Pence.
Yes.
Next year,
I'm not going to invite you
to my birthday party at Mar a Lago.
And people can understand that pressure.
It makes sense.
That's your point.
If you're going to go ahead with charges
to go with.
What people can truly
understand is in part,
this is a document
to convince the public.
Carl, John Eastman,
the lawyer, along with Donald J.
Trump, is who
the committee is referring
for, both obstruction
of official proceeding and conspiracy
to defraud the United States.
Presumably also for the insurrection
and conspiracy charges.
But he's in the end others there.
If so,
he has just responded saying
this is yet another
partizan and political stunt.
That's the
first response that we have
to be expected.
He is a principal conspirator
in what
today was outlined
as a absolute lutely, stunning
cancer, conspiracy to defraud
the United States to prevent
free election
of the president of the United States.
The transfer of power.
But, you know, we started this
by talking about history.
And one of the things we've been asking,
is there another John Dean,
as from in Watergate,
somebody who can bring the house down?
And the answer is potentially yes.
And we got a hint of it today.
Pat Cipollone,
he is the counsel to the president
of the United States,
who in the hearings, we could see him hem
and haw as he took various privileges.
However, he knows everything
Absolutely everything.
There is indications
he is cooperating
with the Justice Department.
Those privileges might not apply.
So I think we better keep our eye
on that substantively
because it is really significant.
And I will just leave us on that
to say
the committee believes the White House
counsel, Pat Cipollone,
he gave a particularly important
account of the events.
They are patting him on the back
and making it clear that he was helpful.